tanks
helicopters
personnel carriers
tens of millions of dollars worth of
equipment all destroyed
and these are just a small portion of
the losses suffered by one of the most
powerful armies in the world
when russia began its offensive it hoped
to capture ukraine's capital kiev within
days
but ukraine's army withstood the assault
evidently the russian army has
endemic problems with morale
with its equipment
with its training and its doctrine
and as a result rasul to answer your
question directly russia has been
defeated in the field to a point where
it was effectively routed from the north
of the country
ukrainian armed forces have taken
advantage often ambushing russian troops
and columns
in less than two months since russia
invaded ukraine its military has lost
thousands of soldiers according to
ukrainian officials it's more than the
united states did in its 20 years of war
in afghanistan and nearly a decade in
iraq combined they say russia has lost
at least
479 tanks
496
infantry fighting vehicles
20 aircrafts
4 ships 32 helicopters
trucks vehicles and jeeps in total the
russians have lost nearly 3 000 pieces
of equipment
and these are considered conservative
estimates
the highest profile lost to date was the
moscow the flagship of russia's black
sea fleet losing a flagship is in during
a war is well really bad it's a bad pr
it's bad it's going to
expand
increase the morale of the ukrainians at
the time when they are on the verge of
losing
marijuana
while many things can be said to have
gone wrong for russians general valerie
says the ukrainian armed forces had a
secret weapon
the mobilization of our society and
people's resistance our pilots who are
older than 60 years old come out and ask
for jets they retired from the armed
forces a long time ago and asked give us
planes and we will destroy the russians
so morale is our formula for success
ukrainian forces have employed new
tactical weapons given to ukraine by
nato allies
chief among them are portable anti-tank
guided missile systems such as the
us-made javelin and its lighter cheaper
cousin and low which have been used
against russian tanks with devastating
effect
in the air the turkish-made 2v2 biracter
drones have carried out both
reconnaissance and strike operations
portable stinger anti-aircraft missiles
have also enabled ukrainian soldiers to
take out low-flying aircraft
as technical miscalculations misjudgment
of the ukrainian resistance and low
morale have all contributed to russian
military vulnerability in this war these
weapons are leveling the playing field
al jazeera cave